rim oda bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
l'article 24 du projet de loi sécurité
globale le plus contesté va être réécrit
par le parlement qu'attendez vous de cet
exercice
alors je sais pas si on peut vraiment
attendre quelque chose
moi je pense qu'on est la réécriture
vont être compliqués je partage un peu
tout ce qui a été dit avant et les
grandes inquiétudes notamment de l'onu
je pense qu'une réécriture veut dire que
l'on continuera à avoir mon sens une
atteinte un peu disproportionné la
réécriture puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on nous dit on nous renvoie au débat
démocratique ont toutes les inquiétudes
qui sont actuellement encore exprimé la
teinte totalement disproportionnée à la
liberté d'expression au droit à
l'information à la liberté de la presse
au regard du but qui serait la
protection des policiers qui sont quand
même largement protégé par ailleurs je
pense ne sera toujours pas résolu on
nous renvoie au débat démocratique
aujourd'hui on voit que la nouvelle
mouture du texte est quand même toujours
pas acceptable que les interrogations
qu'on avait tous et l'indignation et
l'opposition qu'on a exprimé dès le
début des débats à l'assemblée nationale
ont absolument pas été entendu puisque
le texte quelle que soit sa réécriture
va tout de même à un moment donné
conduire à ce que ce soit un journaliste
ou même une personne qui filmeraient
qu'1 voudrais informer finalement la
société et bien d'un comportement d'un
policier ou plus généralement d'un agent
de la force publique
et bien pour être automatiquement
aujourd'hui on voit considéré comme un
trouble à l'ordre public
les difficultés qu'on a c'est que
personne qui vont constater au départ
infractions sont celles justement qui
sont visés donc je ne vois pas comment
juste une réécriture peut en tout cas
tranquilliser le débat ou quoi que ce
soit je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
un contexte
en plus sécuritaire qui nous est
renvoyée systématiquement on a quand
même de nombreux textes on se soulève
contre les atteintes de liberticide
on est vraiment dans un contexte très
inquiétant et ça n'est pas le renvoie au
débat parlementaire qui est là pour nous
rassurer
aujourd'hui le texte qui sort de
l'assemblée nationale tout le monde est
d'accord que ce texte n'est pas bon la
première réaction a quand même été de
tenter de retirer ce texte du débat
parlementaire pour le soumettre un
espèce de commissions indépendantes
levée de boucliers générale on revient
sur le débat mais aujourd'hui je
comprend effectivement que et bien
l'ensemble des personnes concernées et
plus généralement effectivement de la
société considère qui est d atteindre
liberticide grave au regard de ce texte
donc là encore je ne suis pas certain
qu'on ait besoin d'un texte particulier
alors qu'il y a déjà tout un arsenal qui
permet tout de même et bien la
protection cas échéant des forces de
police dans certains cas et notamment
dans le cadre de l'exercice de leurs
fonctions adorable petit existants alors
vous l'avez dit nous sommes dans un
contexte assez tendu est ce que
globalement vous remarqué une tendance
au recul des droits en général et des
libertés individuelles en particulier
depuis notamment le début de la crise
sanitaire
alors oui je pense que très clairement
mais c'était même avant je pense que on
est sur cette dérive de de plus en plus
générale l'exemple même c'est le recours
à l'ordonnancé de manière systématique
qui vous dire que on a pas de débat on a
commencé quand même avant même la crise
sanitaire par ce fameux recours à
l'article 49 3 sur ce texte de la
réforme des retraites qui était quand
même juste coupé court au débat
parlementaire
on a encore l'annnonce de du calendrier
sur la réforme du droit des mineurs de
la semaine prochaine que des textes qui
s' est un texte majeur qui seraient vus
en à peine trois jours qui est
totalement aberrant
au regard des droits de l'enfant je
pense que la défenseure des droits là
encore n'arrête pas de lancer des
alertes rien être entendu aujourd'hui on
a même des observateurs internationaux
qui s'inquiètent du contexte
oui c'est très inquiétant et aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que les gens continuent à
aller dans la rue quand bien même on
leur dit qu'il ya un renvoi au débat
démocratique
parce que on est sur des lois de plus en
plus liberticides
merci beaucoup en tout cas kathleen
catherine de tapas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocate et présidente de la fédération
nationale des unions de jeunes avocats